Hi, everyone. In this lesson,
we're going to take those material functions that we built
and bring them into a parent material
to create the layered effect. Let's get started.
One thing I want to point out that you'll
notice is the material function for
the wood has two function inputs,
but the moss does not.
The moss is going to lay on top,
so it doesn't really need any function inputs
to be able to create some functionality.
It's really just there to lay on top of the wood.
Just keep that in mind.
We did not create any function inputs for it because
the wood is going to be our target that we want to send things to.
Let me show you exactly what I mean.
Let's go ahead and create a parent material
for our two material functions.
Let's go to the content drawer here.
I'll move this to the side just for a second.
We'll open them up in just a bit.
Let's right-click in here.
Let's make sure we apply too because we did that.
In my case, I'm just going to hit apply for
my materials because I don't want to save these.
I want to be able to keep
the class files that you have free and clear.
Let's go to the content drawer here and let's go on right-click.
We're going to create a parent material.
We'll click here and we'll call this
m underscore layered moss underscore wood.
That works for us.
Let's go and double-click on that,
pull that over with our two materials that we made.
Let's go and do that.
One second, off-screen, pulling them over right now.
There we go. We're now going to need to build these out.
Now, how we're going to build these
out is going to make it in such a way,
so we simply just call upon them.
But there's one thing I want to remind you of.
We went over this in other classes and you may have forgotten,
but this is really important when you make material functions.
You want to click on that grid.
Let's go full-screen temporarily here.
We want to say expose the library.
This now allows us to call upon it
if we wanted to look it up within the grid.
Now, we can't just drag them into the scene if you wanted to,
but this makes things a bit easier,
so that allows us to be able to call upon them,
do a quick search to get them in the scene.
Let's do the same thing here and
we'll click on Expose Library right there.
Awesome. Let's go back into
our parent material that we have already set up,
and let's go ahead and put that into place.
First up, let's go and call up the wood material we made,
and you'll see the function inputs active and ready to go.
I'll go ahead and call that out.
We call this mf underscore wood,
and we can see that we have
a wood one that's already done from another class,
but let's make sure that our wood new is ready.
I hit Apply there.
Let's see if he's going to come up here in the search.
If he doesn't, we'll have to hit Save, and that's okay.
Your own function underscore wood.
There it goes, wood new.
Click on that, and it's ready to go.
I'll zoom in so you can see it a bit better. Pretty awesome.
Now with this in place,
we want to go ahead and create the,
promote this to a variable,
the normal multiplier, and we'll set that to one,
so it turns on, so we can see it in screen.
Then next, we want to go ahead and pull in a tint,
and this can be pretty much a color vector.
We can say promote to parameter,
and it'll understand that we're using a vector.
This will be our tint here,
and we'll just get that color the way that we want,
whatever you want, otherworldly bark,
actual bark color, that works for now.
It's a little bit brighter than probably we need, but that's cool.
And then we're going to need a thing called
a material layer blend material function.
Yes, that's right.
We have material functions for everything,
ladies and gentlemen.
So I'm going to go to a matte layer.
Let me get this guy in here.
MA120 layer, and we'll type in blend.
Always do that, always put like an extra T.
There we go.
Matte layer blend, simple.
Now this simple is going to take that wood
for the base material.
This allows us to separate what's on top
and what's on the bottom.
We didn't need a whole lot of complicated detail
for the moss because we really are just
plugging in the moss.
Now, if we wanted to, we could treat it like the wood
and add a normal multiplier for it and a tint.
We can totally do that, but I kept it pretty simple
so you get the idea of how these blend.
So let's go ahead and call it the moss now,
M F underscore moss.
Let's make sure we apply the moss that we have here.
Hit apply because we expose that library.
And now we'll be able to M F underscore moss.
There you go, there's the new one.
And we're going to pull that right into the top material.
There we go.
Now we're going to call up the world align blend.
This is going to again, make it so that everything's
showing up and pointing to the top.
I'm going to pull that into the alpha.
We're going to go ahead and get a blend sharpness.
So we can actually just say promote parameter,
set that to like maybe a 10, if you want to, or a five,
I'll set it for five for now.
And then four, we'll do a blend bias.
So right click, promote to parameter, move this over.
Sometimes I say promote a variable.
If I did, please forgive me.
That is a blueprint habit.
So now let's go ahead and set that.
I think to a negative one might work again.
You can adjust these the way that you need.
All right.
So now that we have that,
let's actually click on our grid and say, Hey, unreal,
this material needs to use material attributes.
Click on here.
And then now we're going to bring this right into that
material attribute.
And you'll see that we have moss.
Pretty cool.
Let's actually see this in scene and you'll see what I'm
talking about.
So I'm going to hit apply.
Let's go and find this parent material.
There it is.
I'm going to pull this over just for a second.
We can now drag this on this sphere.
So now wherever I move this sphere, this object,
it'll show the moss on the top, which is pretty great.
We now made a layered material.
Now you can do multiple layer materials,
creating multiple material functions,
just like we did here with the wood.
You can actually expand on the moss,
get yourself a normal control, wood control,
even or a roughness control.
And you can do the same thing if you wanted to create
multiple ones.
So this is a simple blend,
but we have multiple blends material layers.
You can actually work with if you wanted to,
and you can expand upon those functions as much as you
need.
And that keeps things pretty simple overall,
just with the two and you will see,
and I should say material functions,
you will see several different ones.
We even have, this is an earlier moss one,
but we have like normal strength.
And some of these can be used definitely when it comes to
blending and creating your layered material.
So you can actually combo these with your material
functions.
You can put a material function again,
inside a material function to get the functionality that
you need.
But you got to make sure when you are building these,
that you are such in the case of the wood using
functional function inputs,
super important to use these function inputs,
because that'll open up areas.
And also in the moss, you could add them in later,
but hopefully that gives you an idea of how to create a
simple layer material based on those inputs.
The next thing in the next video,
we're going to go and take a look at a more complex
layered material.
One that I created for Disney when it comes to working
with snow and putting snow on an object.
And as a few more properties exposed,
and I'll walk you through what I did to build that.
Thanks again.